[Aplausos]
[Música]
Y si te dijera que la guerra de Irak ha
sido quizás la mayor estupidez
estratégica de los Estados Unidos en los
últimos 30 años al menos teniendo en
cuenta eso que se llama la real politic
pensando por un momento Cuáles son las
principales amenazas para los intereses
y la seguridad de Washington china Rusia
Corea del Norte e Irán ojo Porque Irán
Es toda una potencia regional en Oriente
próximo tienen casi 90 millones de
habitantes y recursos naturales a punta
pala con las segundas mayores reservas
de gas natural del mundo y las cuartas
de petróleo en pocas palabras Irán ocupa
una posición estratégica fundamental en
Oriente próximo y además Teherán está a
punto de desarrollar su propia bomba
atómica Pues bien teniendo que lidiar
con semejante adversario en este Rincón
del planeta resulta que el mayor muro de
contención frente al expansionismo iraní
no era otro que Sadam husein
[Música]
habéis oído bien el iraq era una
dictadura salvaje Sí pero era
absolutamente antiiran Y entonces llega
a Estados Unidos hace 20 años y no se le
ocurre mejor cosa que hacer que dejar
Irak en bandeja de plata a Irán Ale toma
para ti todo puede que os parezca que
estoy exagerando pero 20 años después os
aseguro que así es como han sido las
cosas de hecho seguramente muchos
recordaréis que Cuando comenzó la guerra
de Irak se pasaban memes en el internet
de aquella época como este Bueno pues
por extraño que parezca esto es
exactamente lo que ha pasado porque hoy
en día hay una democracia en Irak ahora
bien Quién se ha hecho con el poder en
la democracia iraquí pues ni más ni
menos que los líderes sí es más próximos
a Irán es más os acordáis de casa en
solimani el comandante de la fuerza cuts
Pues bien este general iraní campaba sus
anchas por Irak organizando las milicias
que operan en el país de hecho Estados
Unidos logró acabar con el general
solimán y en Bagdad y para que veáis
cómo están las cosas la capital era aquí
ha sumado un nuevo lugar de interés a
sus guías turísticas atentos los restos
del ataque con drones de Estados Unidos
mataron a casebsolimani y abumady
almuján
un sitio conmemorativo en la carretera
del aeropuerto de Bagdad una cosa me
tenéis que reconocer en turno Einstein
tiene más gusto para hacer monumentos
Pero bueno vamos a volver a lo
importante el resumen es que Irán
representa una amenaza cada vez mayor a
medida que está cada vez más cerca de
tener la bomba atómica y ahora encima
está expandiéndose influencia sobre Irak
que recordad es el cuarto mayor
exportador de petróleo del mundo y el
segundo mayor dentro de la upep sin
embargo mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik la situación podría estar
a punto de cambiar a favor de Estados
Unidos así que la pregunta es hasta qué
punto podría evaporarse la influencia
iraní sobre irá Qué papel jugará este
señor que ahora mismo estáis viendo en
pantalla y que parece más el malo de una
película de Disney que un líder político
iraquí Pues bien hoy en visualpolitik
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
enemigos íntimos
antes de seguir hay tres ideas claves
que quiero recordaros la primera que ya
os hemos mencionado un montón de veces
aquí en visualpolitik es que dentro del
mundo islámico se vive una guerra fría
eterna entre las dos principales
corrientes del islam el sunismo y el
sismo la entre ambas ramas de la
religión musulmana proviene del año 632
después de Cristo cuando se decidió
quién debía suceder a Mahoma Así que a
estas alturas no esperéis que vengan con
un acuerdo última hora pero lo cierto Es
que a día de hoy alrededor del 80% de
los musulmanes de todo el mundo son
sunies sin embargo la República islámica
de Irán es territorio completamente
chiíta y en menor medida también lo es
Irak donde los chiíes son el 65% de la
población frente al 30% y esto nos lleva
a una segunda idea importante el Irak de
sarant husein era gobernado por una
élite sunita a pesar de tener una
mayoría social chiquita y para la
tercera idea es mejor que echéis un
vistazo a este mapa aquí podéis
comprobar que Irán e Irak son dos países
que además de tener un nombre muy
parecido son vecinos y además de los que
no se llevan nada bien estuvieron
enfrentados durante décadas desde que el
socialismo árabe se impuso en ira un
nacionalismo que incluía
reivindicaciones territoriales sobre
Irán de hecho Sadam husein invadió irán
a principios de los años 80 luego Irán
lanzó su contraofensiva sobre Irak y la
guerra duró ocho años y no sirvió para
nada las fronteras no cambiaron Eso sí
ambos países quedaron arruinados
mientras provocaban aproximadamente un
millón de Muertos luego vendría la
invasión de kubai la guerra del Golfo y
finalmente la invasión de Irak en 2003 y
es Entonces cuando empieza a cobrar
protagonismo este señor que veis en
pantalla hablamos de
saber es un clerigo hijo del Gran ayato
la amohamed su padre fue una autoridad
religiosa importante para los chiles de
Irak condenados a pertenecer a las
clases sociales más desfavorecidas
durante la dura represión ejercida por
el régimen sunita de San José y como
ayatola se dedicó a predicar sobre
cuestiones sociales y económicas que
afectaban a la vida de las personas por
lo que también se convirtió en un
referente político para los chies su
éxito provocó que fuera asesinado por el
régimen de Sadam en 1999
eran la principal oposición al régimen
de saddam de hecho después de su caída
algunos de sus líderes cooperaron con
Estados Unidos para trabajar juntos en
la creación del nuevo Irak no fue el
caso de muktada al sader que se opuso de
forma radical a la ocupación
estadounidense muchos chiíes que ya
habían seguido a su padre el gran
ayatola al sader vieron en su hijo un
símbolo de la resistencia frente al
Invasor de ese modo mudada se convirtió
en uno de los líderes más conocidos de
la insurgencia iraquí con gran poder
influencia en el centro y sur del país
así como en Bagdad en el suburbio de
alzaura de la capital que es hoy
conocido como la ciudad alzader Pues
bien para combatir contra las tropas
invasoras multa de alsader creó una
milicia el ejército de all Maggie
operativa entre 2003 y 2008 esta milicia
reforzó el estatus de murtada all sader
como uno de los hombres más influyentes
del nuevo Irak sin embargo mis queridos
amigos de visualpolitik esta no era el
mejor camino para llegar al poder porque
como os decía antes Estados Unidos
instauró en Irak una democracia y claro
en la población era aquí los chiíes son
mayoría Así que la iato al aire aquí Ali
hizo un llamamiento a los diferentes
partidos chiíes para que presentaran una
lista única las primeras elecciones
libres que celebraron mutada al sader y
el resto de líderes accedieron y la
alianza iraquí unida se hizo con la
victoria en las elecciones del año 2005
la alianza iraquí unida traicionó
rápidamente su nombre en 2007 la
coalición saltaba por los aires dando
lugar a una nueva pugna para hacerse con
el liderazgo político Sí el principal
beneficiado fue el primer ministro Nuria
el maliki antiguamente exiliado en Irán
desde donde consiguió apoyo financiero
para la oposición Isla
incrementó su popularidad entre los
iraquíes desde el cargo de Primer
Ministro al mejorar la seguridad dentro
del país
desde entonces se ha ido moviendo en
política de forma bastante pragmática
concedió o retiró el apoyo del
movimiento sadista en función de la
influencia que pudiera conseguir sobre
los diferentes ministros y ya sé lo que
os estaréis preguntando En qué se basa
su ideología pues en dos Pilares el
pensamiento religioso chi y el
nacionalismo iraquí por ello siempre se
ha mostrado contrario a las injerencias
extranjeras vengan de donde vengan y Eso
incluye a Estados Unidos pero también a
Irán las tropas estadounidenses se
retiraron en diciembre del año 2011 sin
embargo una nueva amenaza comenzó a
extenderse sobre Irak en el año 2014 de
qué estamos hablando atentos al mapa
el daes el estado islámico puso en Jaque
al nuevo estadio iraquí seguidores de
una versión extrema del islam suni
extendieron los dominios de su califato
hasta faluya apenas 69 km de Bagdad ante
la incapacidad del ejército iraquí para
hacerles frente las distintas fuerzas
chiíes formaron sus propias milicias
paramilitares y también mutada al sader
que recuperó su antigua milicia del
ejército al Magic Después de tres años
de guerra consiguieron la victoria pero
a pesar de ello las milicias
paramilitares chiíes que cuentan con el
respaldo de Irán no sean disueltos por
su parte mutadal sader emprendió una
estrategia de oposición al gobierno que
le ha dado resultado ahora el movimiento
sacrista ha llegado a convertirse en el
grupo más grande de todo el parlamento
de Irak como lo ha conseguido Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
Ábrete sésamo
hay una cosa donde la democracia iraquí
se parece mucho a las democracias
occidentales Y es que apenas una década
después de que empezaran a votar la
gente ya estaba harta de sus políticos
desde el año 2018 la participación en
las elecciones se ha desplomado al 44%
mientras sus rivales han caído en el
descrédito mutadal sader ha sabido
mantener a sus fieles e incluso
incrementar sus votantes y esto se ha
traducido en una mayor influencia sobre
los asuntos iraquíes de hecho en las
negociaciones parlamentarias Ha obtenido
su cuota de empleos en las empresas
públicas para ofrecérselos a sus
seguidores la creación de estas redes
clientelares ha ido fortaleciendo y
ampliando su base social mutada al sader
ha pasado así de ser un simple señor de
la guerra a todo un maestro de las artes
políticas algo Bastante sorprendente
viendo que los últimos años Irak está
dando por fin alguna que otra buena
noticia la zona verde de Bagdad crea el
público después de 16 años la zona verde
era la única zona segura dentro de la
propia Bagdad es donde se ubica por
ejemplo la embajada estadounidense así
como diversos edificios gubernamentales
durante todos años ha sido una zona
blindada porque desde la invasión
estadounidense de Irak el país era un
auténtico polvorín que ahora vuelva a
estar abierta al público es la mejor
señal de que la situación vuelve a ser
relativamente tranquila y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos pero vamos a
ver Fonseca Entonces a qué viene tanto
descontento Pues bien la cuestión es que
muchos iraquíes están viendo como sus
gobernantes están más pendientes de
atender los deseos de Irán que los
deseos de trabajar por los intereses
nacionales Irak es un país muy rico en
petróleo sin embargo la población No
termina de ver los beneficios de todo
ese zumo de dinosaurio algo que Es
evidente si echamos un vistazo a los
presupuestos del estado iraquí
[Música]
el presupuesto dirá que asciende a unos
90.000 millones de dólares en el gráfico
podéis ver marcado como aproximadamente
dos tercios son engullidos por Los
sueldos y las pensiones de los
trabajadores del sector público si a eso
le sumamos los gastos de capital Lo
cierto es que queda una parte muy
reducida del presupuesto para las
inversiones que se precisan para mejorar
el nivel de vida de los iraquíes
precisamente un sector que necesita
inversiones es el energético por ejemplo
Irak tiene unas reservas de gas 5 veces
más grandes que las de omán Sin embargo
su producción es cuatro veces menor es
una producción tan escasa que apenas
cubre la mitad del consumo del país y la
realidad es aún más Escandalosa resulta
que irá que está quemando buena parte
del gas natural que sale de sus pozos
petrolíferos porque simplemente no tiene
la infraestructura necesaria para
capturar Y aprovechar ese gas y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos pero está
aquí en beneficia Quién es el principal
beneficiado de que Irak necesite
importar gas natural Pues atentos porque
esta jugada seguro que no la visteis
venir Irak debe ir a 11.000 millones de
dólares por importaciones de gas según
el embajador iraní Exacto Irán esto le
viene Genial porque las canciones
estadounidenses le impiden exportar sus
recursos naturales pero Washington
coincide exenciones a Irak porque el
país evidentemente necesita ese gas
iraní para cubrir un tercio de su
producción de Electricidad De hecho
cuando hay problemas con el suministro
de gas de Irán se producen apagones los
que habéis visualpolitik desde hace
mucho tiempo ya sabéis que muchas veces
repetimos que los países que no tienen
asegu suministro energético tiene
muchísimas dificultades para que sus
sectores económicos prosperen esto lo
entiende todo el mundo también los
iraquíes que están indignados al
comprobar que sus gobernantes sirven más
a los intereses iraníes que a los del
propio estadio iraquí sin embargo Esto
es algo que está cayendo por su propio
peso y ojo no es por una cuestión
religiosa ni muchísimo menos
[Música]
como es obvio los iraquíes se preguntan
que qué hace el gobierno con el récord
de ingresos en 2022 del sector
petrolífero 115.000 millones de dólares
Ni más ni menos y claro cuando tienen
las respuestas Pues es que es mucho peor
el atraco del siglo Cómo se saquearon
2500 millones de dólares de los fondos
estatales iraquíes en iraq están de moda
ahora los trabajadores fantasmas no
existen pero cobran sus nóminas vamos
que los gobernantes han encontrado
ficticiamente las listas de trabajadores
públicos para meterse sus sueldos en el
bolsillo se estima que un 10% de los
empleados públicos en Irak son
trabajadores fantasmas Así que sí irá
que ha evolucionado mucho y cada vez es
más seguro y hay más democracia Pero
también es un país hiper corrupto en
otro lugar la gente lo criticaría y
diría Oye mira que sinvergüenzas este
político se lo ha llevado crudo y ya
pero en Irak no es tan sencillo Porque
el país tiene petróleo por un tubo
técnicamente su renta per cápita es la
de un país como Jordania sin embargo el
nivel de vida no es equivalente los
servicios públicos dejan bastante que
desear e incluso sigue habiendo cortes
de electricidad a día de hoy y diréis
vale Pero esto muy importante pues
hombre eso es precisamente lo que hizo
que los talibanes volvieran a hacerse
con el poder en Afganistán la gente
estaba harta de la corrupción y de que
las instituciones del estado no
funcionaran en el caso de Irak Cómo
puede cambiar esta situación Pues
atentos
[Aplausos]
el enemigo de mi enemigo
los iraquíes ya estallaron contra su
gobierno en las grandes protestas
durante otoño de 2019 reclamaban el fin
de la corrupción y mejores servicios
públicos cosa bastante lógica y de hecho
lograron la dimisión del Primer Ministro
sin embargo los manifestantes fueron
brutalmente reprimidos pero no a manos
de quienes os podríais imaginar No
fueron los cuerpos de seguridad del
Estado sino las milicias chiíes que
únicamente rinden cuentas a Irán las
mismas que esperaban órdenes del General
solimán y esta represión pasó factura en
2021 a los partidos políticos
respaldados por Irán encabezados por el
Antiguo Primer Ministro nurial maliki el
movimiento sadista anunció que buscaría
Un gobierno que excluyera a todas las
facciones plurales gobierno por y para
Irak y ojo porque consiguieron
importantes aliados para ellos más South
barfany líder del kurdistán iraquí y
mohamedzi referente de los unitas
iraquíes de hecho el propio jaboutsi se
pronunciaba así sobre las negociaciones
con arshard el tiempo de la
interferencia extranjera en la formación
de los gobiernos iraquíes ha terminado y
hoy las montañas y los desiertos derax
se está moviendo hacia el honorable para
discutir sobre un gobierno iraquí
puramente nacional ni Oriental ni
occidental Mohamed alboussi ni este ni
oeste este este es el eslogan favorito
de alzader para describir Cómo debe ser
el gobierno de Irak
[Música]
una proclama nacionalista iraquí opuesta
Igualmente tanto a las injerencias
estadounidenses como a las iranías Y eso
Por supuesto Deja atrás todos los
mandatos religiosos chies para construir
un nuevo Irak que de la mano a los
sunitas y a los kurdos ahora bien
Mientras tanto Irán no se mantuvo de
brazos cruzados atentos Irán aumenta la
presión sobre los líderes kurdos y su
unidad dirac para romper la alianza de
saber Irán ha lanzado ataques con
misiles y drones contra el kurdistán
iraquí Asimismo el tribunal supremo de
Irak prohibió las exportaciones de
petróleo de esta región Autónoma
dejándola sin su principal fuente de
ingresos Respecto a los unitas la
presión fue ejercida por parte de las
milicias que actúan de forma violenta y
con total impunidad en las áreas de
mayoría en un intento de forzar unas
elecciones anticipadas al sader ordenó
dimitir a todos sus diputados una jugada
que ha salido bastante mal
al desaparecer los representantes del
movimiento sabrista del parlamento sus
escaños fueron ocupados por miembros de
los partidos Pro iraníes estas fuerzas
lograron formar un nuevo gobierno si al
sudani un antiguo ministro de almaliki
Los partidarios del movimiento zarista
realizaron protestas en Bagdad que
derivaron en enfrentamientos violentos
contra las misas respaldadas por Irán
Irak estuvo al borde de la guerra civil
hasta que mudakader ordenó La retirada
de sus seguidores
pero esperad un momento porque la
presión iraní también llega al terreno
religioso porque una doctrina central en
islam es el concepto de marja significa
que cada musulmán tiene que tener un
líder espiritual cuyos edicto se sigan
incuestionablemente Pues bien el padre
de muktada El ayatolá Mohamed sí que
tenían las calificaciones para ser un
líder espiritual Pero mutada el hijo no
Así que cuando el padre de alzader fue
asesinado Los Seguidores del movimiento
sadista se vieron obligados a seguir a
otro clérigo en cuestiones religiosas y
así es como recurrieron a la ayatola
era normalmente una tarea vitalicia pero
parece que ahora ya no lo es aljaire Y
se retira de trabajar como autoridad
religiosa y aconseja a los creyentes que
sigan la autoridad de jamen habéis oído
bien ningún marha renuncia en vida y
encima que siendo la autoridad ir aquí
reconozca la autoridad religiosa de
jamenei El Líder supremo de Irán todo
indica que Teherán influyó en su
decisión con el objetivo de reducir el
poder de alzader pero esta jugada para
dominar a Los partidarios del movimiento
sadista ha fracasado sus seguidores han
permanecido leales y el nacionalismo
iraquí que antepone los intereses
políticos sobre los religiosos sale
reforzado evidentemente de murptadal
sader no es el Aliado perfecto de los
Estados Unidos pero visto lo visto en
Irak puede ser la opción menos mala un
Irak fuerte gobernado por una coalición
de chihiís suníes y kurdos que se
opongan al dominio y a mí y que permita
Washington desviar su atención a otras
amenazas de mayor calado como Rusia o
china no suena muy mal verdad Pero ahora
turno para vosotros Hasta qué punto
puede haber un Irak democrático sin
corrupción y alejado de los intereses
iraníes creéis que la oposición de
murptadal sader Sería beneficiosa para
Estados Unidos podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]